key afghan cities are falling to the
radical islamic taliban with
unprecedented speed with international
troops largely gone the militants are
escalating their offensive capturing
wide swathes of countryside and nine
provincial capitals including kunduz
once a center of resistance to the
taliban and the site of the german
bundeswehr base hundreds of thousands of
civilians are fleeing conditions are
desperate for many of those who've been
displaced our question today
taliban advance is afghanistan lost
[Music]
welcome to to the point
joining us in the studio sandra
pettisman afghanistan expert with
deutsche welle's invested kid unit and
she says germany needs to conduct a
ruthless and independent review of its
most expensive and bloodiest foreign
mission to date also a pleasure to
welcome thomas rutty he is co-director
of the independent think tank
afghanistan analyst network and he says
the west quite simply got it wrong and
must bear the bulk of the blame for the
current crisis in afghanistan
and joining us from bonn is ahmed wali
akasai he is from dw's dari and pashtu
desk and he argues that the over hasty
invasion of afghanistan was a mistake
the planless exit is a catastrophe
so let us start with a look at what's
happening right now in the country and
wally if i may uh begin with you you say
that the planless exit is a catastrophe
what are you hearing from friends and
relatives in afghanistan about the
situation at the moment
we are able to see the current situation
in social media live we see how
people are living in kandahar in hillman
and in other provinces where the war is
going on
where people have no shelter where
internal displaced people
are searching for refuge where women
children
and old men do not know what will happen
tomorrow
a kind of perspective less of
perspectivelessness is uh overwhelming
all
or the most the people that we talk to
so uh it is very tough for all afghans
at the moment especially for those
who live uh
in the war areas and war is everywhere
welly what are people expecting some
analysts are saying that if the taliban
could so easily take these areas in the
north which are actually non-pashtun
areas where there used to be
considerable resistance to the taliban
that they will undoubtedly overrun the
capital of kabul within months would you
agree with that
we have the latest
analysis of the
u.s military and they think that it is
possible that even
in few weeks the taliban may overrun
kabul the afghan government is deeply
divided internally
and also seems to be completely
overwhelmed especially now that the
necessary air support from foreign
troops as
well as the necessary logistical help is
no longer there uh or really limited
this is why the
u.s military uh things also that uh um
taliban may take kabul very soon and
it really may be the case
sandra as you say this was germany's
longest foreign mission to date how do
people in afghanistan
now see the western troops and the
western countries who fought so long and
are now so hastily beating a retreat
let me tell you what my friends are
telling me who are still on the ground
who are fearing for their future for
their lives occasionally depending on
where in the country they are
there is a sense of
betrayal
there is a sense of
you leave us alone with this mess that
you created
perspectivelessness is something that
wali has already mentioned where do we
go from here
so the sense of betrayal is real and i
can understand that because the
situation that we see in afghanistan on
the ground right now civil war being
developing in the country on a daily
basis reaching ever closer to the
capital kabul that is something that the
afghans
have not created that comes from
elsewhere and we have to look back at
all the mistakes that were made very
early on when this international
intervention started on 7th of october
2001 when the first u.s bombs were
dropped in afghanistan we're going to
take a closer look at that in just a
moment
u.s president joe biden made it clear
this week that the u.s won't be putting
any more boots on the ground let's hear
what he had to say
they've got to fight for themselves
fight for their nation
the united states
i'll insist we continue
to keep the commitments we made
providing close air support
making sure that their air force
functions and is operable
resupplying
their forces with food and equipment
and paying all their salaries
but they've got to want to fight
president biden clearly implying there
that the pretty well-equipped government
forces could be fighting harder would
you absolve you said in your opening
statement that the west must bear the
bulk of the blame but would you absolve
the government uh and the army uh the
afghan army of responsibility for this
mess yeah i mean the statement from my
point of view puts things a little bit
upside down i mean where the u.s with
their separate agreement with the
taliban
who pulled the carpet from under the
feet of the african government and the
afghan forces and are largely
responsible for
the drop in morale but that
started much earlier of course because
first the combat mission went wrong the
taliban became stronger not weaker
and then there was that what i see as a
fig leaf mission resolute support
training equipping the afghan army and
saying okay you're now responsible alone
after us and other troops were not able
to defeat the taliban before so i think
that's a little bit
putting the blame
onto the weaker party
that backup support that biden mentioned
air cover and and so on how much of a
different difference will that make i'm
afraid it wouldn't make too much of a
difference you can stop the taliban here
and there probably for a while if you
have an intensive bombing campaign you
probably
can even force them to sit down and
start talking again which would be uh
positive but we also need to say that at
the receiving end it's not only taliban
uh there's fighting ongoing in urban
centers there's a lot of civilians and
they're harmed by the fire and the bombs
and the shelling of both sides and if
you are at the receiving end as an
abraham
in the end it doesn't make a difference
for you whether it's an american bomb or
a taliban shell
at any rate
u.s president joe biden has clearly made
it his mission to bring closure on a
foreign war that began as we heard
nearly 20 years ago
after the 9 11 terrorist attacks on the
world trade center the united states and
its allies invaded afghanistan
their common goal was to eliminate the
al-qaeda terrorist organization and its
leader osama bin laden
the country occupied by the islamist
taliban was no longer to be a haven for
terrorists from around the world
but the construction of a stable civil
society and democracy was not successful
corruption and drug trafficking continue
to flourish whilst most of the
population lives in abject poverty
and the taliban could not be defeated
either
in return some 3 500 servicemen and
women of nato and its allies have died
in afghanistan so far
the 2020 doha deal between the u.s and
the taliban also failed to bring about
peace
the mission's lack of prospects and
escalating costs nevertheless persuaded
the united states to withdraw
the departure of the allied troops also
marks the end of the costliest mission
in the history of the german armed
forces
so was it all for nothing
and let me put that question straight
away to wally wali the fact is the
western forces did manage to kill osama
bin laden they did decimate al-qaeda
they did reduce the taliban's influence
sufficiently for elections to be held
and for some afghan girls to go to
school was it nonetheless all a mistake
there were many mistakes made um talks
with taliban should have been should
have taken place as early as 2001 and
one should not only have relied on the
military mape
that's what we had unfortunately now as
well that biden is talking about war
there is no military solution for this
conflict uh and recognizing former armed
groups and militias providing them with
money facilities and weapons and making
them partners was a very very big mystic
if one was hoping to pacify uh the
country through disarmament and
democratization as a result what we have
in afghanistan right now is a kind of
solid democracy in addition the regional
players which should have helped
forge a solution were not involved in
the way that they should have been and
the things that we call
which has achieved in 20 years they are
really very fragile and without peace
all those things will be vanished very
soon sandra how do you say it i would
completely agree with wali i mean
what we've seen the past 20 years is
really
that
military the military footprint
always triumphed over
diplomacy politics developmental aid and
you can't solve a conflict like the one
in afghanistan which was already 20
years old before the intervention even
started
with just throwing troops and money at
the situation and thinking that with
airstrikes night raids drone attacks you
will solve the problem and you will you
know bring democracy to afghanistan
that's way too easy there wasn't a clear
blueprint of how to go about it and that
always the military was in a driving
seat right from the start
um entering
bad alliances with warlords because you
had the same enemy that was something
that led in afghanistan to a very weak
and hollow and corrupt state
which could not carry democracy and we
see the effects of that now unfolding
because the civil war is back in full
swing
thomas the afghan government
and taliban leaders are still officially
conducting negotiations
and
still talking about a peace process the
biden administration clearly hopes that
that can still yield some form of
negotiated power sharing agreement is
that completely illusory would you say i
wouldn't say completely illusory but the
approach in the beginning which excluded
the afghan government
was a big mistake i mean the
talks if we look at it are not conducted
between the taliban and the afghan
government but about
with a delegation from kabul which
represents not only the government but
other political factions because taliban
do not recognize the african government
don't want to talk with them
directly i mean it would be high time
now to put pressure uh on both sides
actually to start talking there from
up to now that has only been a very very
little progress i mean they even didn't
manage to finalize an agenda so um
yeah
those negotiations started wrong but the
only hope actually is to put them on the
right footing and probably there's a
chance in the taliban advances that they
come to a point that's a hope uh not a
prediction that they say okay we are so
strong now we can sit down and talk but
they will of course dictate their
conditions and it will not be up to the
afghan government unfortunately central
taliban leaders say that they do favor a
political settlement uh afghan president
uh assaf ghani says
he sees no evidence whatsoever of that
do you see any
i mean obviously i'm here in berlin
watching from afar but i see a clear
disconnect between the messaging that
comes from the doha office which is
essentially the political office of the
taliban and what is happening on the
ground with the commanders
commandeering this lightning offensives
multiple lightning offensives that we
see because it's in so many different
parts of the country and we see so many
various pictures you have districts
where girl schools for instance remain
open and others where they are closed
immediately you have areas where music
is still allowed in others where it was
one of the first things that got banned
and of course you hear the messaging of
peace and of
like more moderate voices coming from
doha but what we see on the ground is
a military
militant movement edging ever closer to
the capital kabul and whether we will
see
urban combat there or you know something
like strangulating whoever is in there
cutting them off from supply lines that
is something that i could envisage and
we can only hope as thomas rodriguez
said that at some point either through
pressure or because the momentum is so
high that we can now sit down and talk
it will lead to negotiations back in
doha because the civilian population is
in the crossfire everywhere
welly let me get your take also on that
question about the prospects uh for any
uh real uh officia uh negotiated
settlement but i'd also like to ask you
about the influence of geopolitics
because we're seeing china russia iran
receiving taliban leaders for talks
india acknowledging that they've also
had a back channel
to the taliban so what would you say
would be the consequences of that in
terms of the balance of power both
within afghanistan and in the region as
a
whole well um the taliban they are uh
they think that they are on the road uh
to victory they think that they will
very soon uh take over kabul in this
situation i don't think that
they might see the need to
talks
they want even if they want to talk they
think that they will have
more to dictate
when they have more areas and the
regional
story as also one of the very
sorry ones because in the last 20 years
natto and its allies
they were most the time alone with all
their initiatives there were
no original uh powers uh involved they
did not involve them and now the key uh
solution may uh lie uh uh again so that
um the regional uh
um uh for the regional uh uh countries
that they are uh uh in uh the
negotiations so that they can uh stop
their proxy wars uh in afghanistan
afghan people they don't produce bullets
they don't produce weapons
most afghans that we talk to they ask
themselves where all these weapons come
from so all these things come from
outside in afghanistan most the afghans
think that all the time there are proxy
wars and proxy war going on so
they would have to find the solution the
international community also outside
afghanistan inside afghanistan and in
the region
thomas at the moment one has the
impression that neither in germany uh
nor in the us uh
do citizens really want to think very
much about afghanistan they simply want
it to go away if kabul falls
if we see china getting more involved in
some way with a taliban-led afghanistan
do you think that opinions will change
in washington and or berlin
or is this washing of the hands uh
something that's likely to continue
one of the lessons we should have
learned
over 40 years of conflict in afghanistan
is that it's not up to us to set the
agenda afghanistan sets puts itself on
the agenda very often and that's
happening in the moment i have the
feeling i'm also not sure that the
public is not interested
in afghanistan it's mainly politicians
who have uh relegated afghanistan from
uh foreign foreign policy priority to i
don't know far beyond or far
under uh or behind ukraine and
other issues climate crisis which is not
unimportant
so
i think afghanistan
with the taliban
march towards power has put itself on
the agenda again and we need to react i
mean this decent interval what the u.s
government has hoped uh that was a term
from after the vietnam war has not
happened it's collapsing now while the
last u.s soldiers
are still there and that shows that they
bear a large part of the responsibility
but of course we should not only talk
about the west also the afghan elites
have an
enormous portion of
responsibility for what was happened by
just looking at their own interests
enriching themselves allowing a corrupt
system to grow but we also with open
eyes watch that we as as the west and
while talking about fighting against
corruption and drug
trade we actually allowed our allies to
be involved in that
sandra as the taliban retakes power in
provincial capitals and possibly
ultimately in kabul would you expect it
to revert to its old ways will we see a
new
reign of terror occasionally you hear
voices including from washington saying
surely the taliban cannot have an
interest and and all of these young
girls who went to school
surely it doesn't want to be seen to be
thwarting their
their needs how do you see it i think
it's a little bit of crystal ball
reading i find it very hard to answer
that now
what we see again the messages the
messaging in doha and the political
office is different from what we see on
the ground but there are undoubtedly
radical forces militant islamist forces
within the taliban who really want
nothing else but
to bring back the fundamentalist
islamic emirate which would leave
very very little space for women for
girls for education for a public life
for personal freedoms for personal
choices
and that is one possibility but it is
not the only possibility i think it
really depends on
can the international community and
you've mentioned all the various forces
active there three atomic powers the
united states europe can they come
together in one diplomatic push and
exert pressure to such an extent that
the taliban might
might opt for a political solution power
sharing in afghanistan i mean the
decision-making body in the taliban is
the leadership council which sits
in large parts in pakistan really don't
know what they think
the door office is their foreign office
the military commanders are the defense
ministry so to say the decision
is taken above and that's important we
should not
construct
this uh
differences between those who are the
foreign policy makers and the taliban
and those who are fighting on the ground
the important thing is to get the
leadership to put a break on those
people and those commanders on the
ground who talk about revenge and
killing we will kill all these people
who have worked with the west and so on
which is giving jitters to the people in
afghanistan exactly and that is
precisely the reason why we are seeing
thousands flee as the international
troops depart in the taliban advances
the united nations high commission for
refugees in fact is warning of a looming
humanitarian crisis
fleeing ongoing fighting and the taliban
these afghans have found refuge in a
school there have been nearly 3 million
internally displaced since the military
operation began in afghanistan
more and more people are also making the
dangerous journey to neighboring
countries and europe
turkey the main country of transit is
where most of them get stranded
many in germany and europe now fear a
new wave of refugees and politicians
intend to take this into consideration
as germany's election campaign begins
the debate about afghans living in the
country is intensifying
unlike many other eu countries the
german government has long insisted on
deporting criminal afghan asylum seekers
but it too has suspended deportation
flights
former afghan helpers of the german
armed forces feel particularly
threatened by the advance of the taliban
and are hoping for asylum in germany
but very few are really allowed to enter
is germany abandoning the people of
afghanistan
and wali let me put that question
straight to you as we heard germany has
now suspended these deportation flights
but it certainly hasn't opened its doors
wide to the afghans either who helped
the bundeswehr or those who helped
german development agencies so what
would you say has germany abandoned the
afghan people
germans had a very good
image in germa in afghanistan people in
afghanistan they really trust germans
but that might have changed now in the
last 20 years because
the afghans it was not very clear from
the beginning if the germans were there
uh for uh reconstruction or were they
there for uh war and the decision uh i
can only say it is a very good decision
that no departures uh
to afghanistan but it may uh it would be
better that this decision uh would have
come
earlier you know in germany in europe we
don't have death penalties anymore but
uh deporting people if they are
criminals or not um
removing them from here and depart
deporting them to afghanistan may end
as a death penalty and i think that's
something no one wants
senator
what do you think the west owes to all
of those in afghanistan who believed the
dream that we essentially sold them over
these years a dream of democracy and
human rights
honesty honesty in the sense of let's
really
look at our mistakes made and further
engagement keep humanitarian channels
open invest in development aid we need
to get access to people we need to help
on the ground as much as we can and we
need to decentralize this so bring back
humanitarian aid give it to the
organizations let them reach out to the
people and try to get diplomacy back on
the floor meanwhile thomas migration the
prospect of immigration also from
afghanistan remains an absolute
political hot potato here in germany and
also of course in the u.s the unhcr as i
said is now warning of a looming
humanitarian crisis
most of those who have been displaced so
far are in neighboring countries could
that change will we see a major wave of
migration toward europe i don't see that
because europe has been very restrictive
and most afghans don't make it to europe
anymore but those people on the run
either in the country or outside in the
country in the region are those who we
have a responsibility for because they
flee now this chaos in afghanistan the
return of the taliban and for which we
also have a large part of responsibility
so we have the responsibility to protect
them not only the local employees of
bundeswehr and the civilian ministries
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us here today and thank
you very much to our audience for
joining us see you soon
[Music]
you